>> Here's another way to look at it. Let's say you have a bag of jellybeans.
There's only one licorice, but there are four strawberries and four blueberries.
There's also only one cherry and two lime, or lemon, I don't know, you decide.
If we take a sample of, say, four Jelly Bellies, most likely, we're not going to
get the licorice one. Say we just get these in our sample. This sample doesn't
show the whole range of Jelly Belly flavors that we have, including cherry and
licorice. So our sample underestimates the variability in our Jelly Belly
population. Hopefully, this example lends a little more insight into why we
divide by n minus 1 when calculating the standard deviation of a sample. But
please let's discuss it in the forums. There, we could go into a lot more depth.
For the purposes of this class though, as long as you have a basic intuitive
understanding of the difference between sample standard deviation and population
standard deviation, then you'll be fine.